Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie. So we have to
talk about how Arya Stark is going to be the
most valuable character to Jon Snow in Season
7 because of the stuff that she's done so far.
So just careful for spoilers for everything that's
happened on the show up through Season 6.
Because of the way the TV show has changed her character just a little bit from the books,
she's actually much more powerful on the TV show.
So she is like The Punisher,
that's why wearing my Punisher t-shirt right now. But there's a new round of the Game of Thrones giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
It's just for a copy of one of the
enhanced editions of the books.
So be sure to click that bell to enable alerts so
that you don't miss anything during the off-season.
So number 7, Arya - the most valuable
character - what does that mean?
Isn't Jon Snow? isn't Daenerys?
Aren't they the most valuable characters?
Daenerys controls her dragons,
Jon Snow is now King of the North.
There are number of characters that wield
power in different ways that will be very,
very important down the road. But right now,
they're both characters that are in transition -
they're largely shackled to their forces.
Like Jon Snow can't do whatever he wants to do.
He's trying to figure things out, and the way
the TV show's presented him is that he is not
the best leader of men. That's gonna be one
of the big challenges he has in season 7.
His, you know, leading small groups of people
in earlier seasons went really well,
but how is he going to deal with the collected forces of the North. Arya Stark, on the other hand, currently is
the most valuable character because she's not bound to anyone, even though she's serving her family.
But she can go anywhere, steal any face that she wants. So she has complete free reign of the
seven kingdoms, and there are a couple
things that she's trying to do right now.
Number 6 - revenge is her mission.
She is The Punisher this season.
So, while there might be at some point in the future where she's riding with her family on horseback,
charging an open field,
that's not really what she does.
She trained as an assassin with the Faceless
Men this whole time so that she could use
those skills, and they're probably going to
being taking advantage of that in season 7.
So what did she just do?  She just
assassinated Walder Frey and his sons.
There were some minor changes with the way
they presented that - the TV show version of
Arya just got way more powerful
than the book version.
So some of those changes is why she became
so much more powerful than the other characters.
So number 5 - as of right now, she controls
The Twins because she can wear Walder Frey's face.
She can wear anyone's face that she wants.
So The Twins themselves is actually a very
important location because it's basically
the only way to get an army between the North
and the southern kingdoms. So you're either
stuck in the North or you're stuck in the South.
So she could be very valuable to Jon Snow in the
forces of the North if they try to march on Cersei,
but she could also be a huge pain in Cersei's ass, stopping any of her forces from marching north.
So I'd say she's important for Daenerys' character too,
but Daenerys hasn't made landfall on Westeros yet.
She doesn't know who Arya is, Arya's never
met her, so she's not thinking about her.
She's just thinking about more revenge,
her list, and her family. So number 4 - the
Punisher controls The Twins - chaos reigns.
But because there's so few episodes, this is
probably going to be more useful to getting troops
south than from keeping troops from getting north.
Number 3 - crossing more names off the
list - this is where things get interesting.
because The Hound is still on
her list, but so is The Mountain.
I know everybody wants to go for "Clegane
Bowl 2.0". It was renewed hope after The Hound
joined The Brotherhood during Season 6. So
people are like, it could still happen down the road.
Eventually they will have to clash forces,
and The Hound will be there. But there are only
a couple characters on Arya's list that are
still alive on the TV show right now,
including Cersei, The Hound, and The Mountain.
And I think we can agree that over the course
of Season 6, Arya made it pretty clear how
she feels about The Hound. So even if
she ultimately crosses him off her list,
he is the last person that
she would cross off.
So that leaves Cersei and The Mountain, and
The Mountain is never far from Cersei.
So they kind of come
hand in hand.
What she's been doing this last episode is just
avenging her family's death at the Red Wedding.
So that meant taking care of Walder Frey and all
his sons - everybody that she knew was responsible.
She doesn't know everyone that was involved, she just knows that the Freys were mostly responsible,
and that the Lannisters
sent their regards.
So there are number of ways she could find
herself in proximity to the Lannisters -  like
Jaime and Cersei. So Jaime and Cersei seem
like they're going to be separated for most
of the season anyway because Jaime is leading
the Army, but you get the sense that Arya
does not discriminate because she
baked all of the Freys into pies.
So she is hardcore. So, she's going after Lannisters
now, but even though Cersei is at the top of the list,
it doesn't mean that she's going to
spare every other Lannister.
So number 1 - Valonqar Theory - Cersei is
going to die at the hands of the younger one -
little brother, little sister - the language
is gender-neutral. Everyone just interprets
it as little brother. You know, she will meet
her end at the hands of the little brother.
People used to think that it was Tyrion early on,
but now people seem to think that it's going
to be Jaime. But, because of the way the TV
show has changed Arya's face-stealing,
she is now capable of stealing Jamie's face to
use it to kill Cersei. So poetically Arya is
now the most powerful character, and in fulfillment
of that prophecy you get the younger brother
killing Cersei which sort of wraps up
Jaime and Cersei's arc.
The way Jaime became a good person,
Cersei embraced a darker path.
But you also get Arya being able to cross off
all the names on her list. So it's just a solution
that allows them to wrap up all those storylines
in a really satisfying way, but that also
makes sense for the characters. Jaime, very
tragic figure, wants to die in the arms of
someone he loves. So you can imagine that Arya
will somehow kill Jaime at some point, but
Jaime seems like he is also destined to kill
Cersei in the way that he killed the Mad King,
just because Cersei has now become
a version of the Mad Queen.
So you ask how is that possible?
This is where the TV show changes come in.
So, what the TV show has changed about the
books and face-stealing is that typically
when you steal a phase in the books - like the shape of your body does not change - it's really just the face part.
And you know you can change your facial structure, just a little bit, but that's about as far as it goes.
It's almost like you're wearing a mask that
just looks very, very convincing.
But on the TV show Arya was able to go from being a little girl to a much taller, more fully developed woman.
So what the TV show is saying is that she
could almost steal anyone's face and it would
be a convincing replacement. Now like imagine
her trying to steal The Mountain's face, that
probably wouldn't happen. That'd be taking it too
far. She can't go from being like a little, 5-foot-tall
person to being like and 8-, 9-foot-tall
person. That'd just be ridiculous.
Most of the way they shoot these scenes they cheat that. So, you know, they don't really give away the
fact that she's either
really tall or really short.
So you guys let me know, how far do you think that
Arya is going to take her face-stealing in Season 7?
So if she can still Walder Frey's face, she
can steal anyone's face that she wants.
She just became the most valuable
character to Jon Snow and his forces.
I would say the most powerful character, you
kind of have to say from a narrative perspective -
because it depends on what kind of power you're
talking about. Because there are people with powerful
magic, but they're sort of shackled to their
roles. Like Daenerys can't just take her
dragons and conquer everyone by herself. So
she's, you know, very powerful right now - very
important in the fight against the White Walkers.
But Bran, for instance, has much more powerful magic.
So maybe I should make that my next bonus
video. Like ranking the actual most powerful
people based on how powerful their magic is.
Because typically as you get weaker and weaker,
people's magic gets more and more powerful.
So Melisandre is a very powerful person
because she has great magic, but Bran, who is
even weaker, like he has a giant physical disability -
he has to be carried around on a litter - has much
more powerful magic that he is still trying to
figure out. But because so many of you have been
requesting more Game of Thrones videos - I've only been doing about one a week - I'm gonna start doing more.
So YouTube is actually giving me some upgrades
that will make it easier for you guys to communicate
that with me. Like I can pick it out of the comments,
but sometimes stuff like that gets buried.
So let me know what you want my weekly videos
about Game of Thrones to be about - theories,
or explaining concepts, or groups of people, or history.
Anything you guys want - and like I said I think the trailer's probably at least another month or two away.
They did drop the parody trailer with John Oliver,
but that's like a trailer for all their HBO shows.
Congratulations to this week's book giveaway
winner - Juan Trujillo - please private
message me on the back-end of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video. I'll just announce the winner the next
time I post a Game of Thrones video.
While you guys wait for that to post, you can click
here for my Cersei theory, and you can click here
to rewatch that Logan red-band trailer
Thank you so much for watching - everybody,
let's high-five - I'll see you guys tonight.